IT IS WEEK 15 AND WE ARE HERE.
IS WEAK 15.
WE ARE STILL SURVIVING AND WE
ARE THRIVING.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING TODAY ON
THIS WEEK 15?
WE ARE A LITTLE BIT EARLY.
MONEY IS STILL TO BE MADE
TODAY.
HOW ARE WE DOING?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO CHECK IN
WITH YOU.
RYAN AND I ARE ON THE EAST
COAST.
9:00 AM, WE ARE FINE.
IT IS 6:00 AM IN ARIZONA, HOW
ARE YOU DOING?
>> WE ARE THRIVING AND
SURVIVING OUT HERE IN ARIZONA.
HOW ARE YOU GUYS DOING?
>> YOU MENTIONED THAT GREG IS
ON THE WEST COAST.
SAM, I THINK YOU ARE THE LAST
ONE TO CALL IN HERE, WERE YOU
NOT?
>> I WAS BUT I HAVE A NEWBORN.
I HAVE EXCUSES FOR EVERYTHING.
>> SAM DID JUST GET HERE.
FULL TRANSPARENCY, SAM DID JUST
GET HERE TWO WEEKS AGO.
HE IS FRESH OUT OF THE BEEN
STRAIGHT TO YOU GUYS.
LET ME INTRODUCE EVERYBODY.
LET ME FORMALLY INTRODUCE
EVERYBODY.
MY NAME IS GREG.
NEXT TO ME IS THE MAN I LIKE TO
CALL THE MAN, THE MYTH, AND THE
LEGEND, IT IS SAM RICHMAN.
NEXT TO HIM IS THE MAN THAT
CONNECTS US TO YOU.
IT IS OUR PRODUCER RYAN.
WE ARE GIVING HIM OUR BEST
BETS.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS DROP YOUR
LOTS IN THE CHAT.
WE WILL BE GRADING YOUR PICS AT
THE END OF THE SHOW.
RIGHT NOW, WE NEED YOUR HELP TO
BUILD ANOTHER ANYTIME TOUCHDOWN
PARLAY.
RYAN I AM NOT GOING TO LIE.
I AM TRYING TO WIN TODAY.
>> I AM AS WELL.
>> WE NEED TO GET INTO THE WIN
COLUMN.
WE STARTED OFF BY.
NOW, WE ARE LIKE ONE CHICK LIKE
AWAY.
THE LAST COUPLE WEEKS WE WERE
IN THE WAY.
WE NEED TO GET IN THE WIN
COLUMN.
TODAY, EVERYBODY, WE NEED TO
WIN.
WE NEED WINNERS ONLY PLEASE IN
THE CHAT.
RYAN, TELL US WHAT WE NEED FROM
THE PEOPLE?
TELL THEM AGAIN.'S
>> LET'S REPEAT OURSELVES.
IT IS EARLY, PEOPLE NEED TO
HEAR IT AGAIN.
WE NEED YOUR LUCK.
WE NEED YOU TO GET INTO THE
CHAT AND LET US KNOW SCORING A
TOUCHDOWN TODAY.
WE WILL PLUG IT IN AND WE WILL
DEBATED.
I WILL SAY MY GUY DYLAN IS
REMINDING US THAT LAST WEEK HE
WANTED BOSTON SCOTT IN THE
PARLAY AND BOSTON SCOTT WAS
+550.
I PUT IT IN AND I AM NOT AND I
TOLD YOU SO GUY.
I PUT IT IN AND GREG AND SAM
TOLD ME NOW.
I AM NOT GOING TO PASS BLAME.
I WOULD NEVER PASS BLAME.
I JUST WANT US TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT HAPPENED LAST WEEK.
>> BRIAN, OKAY.
>> [ LAUGHTER ] THAT IS WHAT WE
ARE SAYING.
IT WAS MULTIPLE TIMES WHERE WE
HAD WINNERS LAW IN BUT YOU
WANTED TO GET RICH.
>> YES.
>> WE DO NOT GO TOO FAR INTO
THE PAST.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED A MONTH AGO, TWO
OF THE GO, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED LAST WEEK.
>> ALL RIGHT, FAIR ENOUGH.
>> YOU WANT TO DEBATE A LITTLE
BIT WHILE OUR GUYS SAM FIGURES
THIS STUFF OUT?
YOU DO NOT WANT TO BE A PART OF
THIS.'S
>> OKAY, LET'S DO IT.
WE NEED YOU GUYS TO LET US
KNOW.
DID ANYTHING CATCH YOUR EYE, WE
HAVE TO KIND OF GUY PEOPLE TO
PLAY.
GO AHEAD.
>> SOMETHING CAUGHT MY EYE IN
THE CHAT.
THIS IS WHAT I AM GOING TO DO,
I'M GOING TO STICK MY FLAG DOWN
THERE.
I FEEL LIKE PART OF THIS IS
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE WE OWE HIM
ONE.
ANOTHER PART OF THIS IS BECAUSE
I LOVE THIS.
JUSTIN FIELD IS +125 TODAY.
>> I LIKE THAT.'S EMAC AN
IMPORTANT NOTE AS WELL, BOTH
THEIR OWN MOONEY AND CHASE
CLAYPOOL ARE OUT FOR THE BEARS
TODAY.
THESE ARE THE TOP TWO WEAPONS.
IF THE BEARS ARE GOING TO KEEP
THIS COMPETITIVE TODAY, THE MAN
HAS GOT TO USE HIS LEGS.
I THINK THIS IS WHAT WAS
DECIDED.
LOOK WHO DECIDED TO JOIN.
YOU ARE THE LAST ONE CHICK IN
AND YOU ABOUT FOR THE ANYTIME
TV PARLAY.
>> WHAT DO YOU WANT FROM ME?
>> I WOULD LIKE NOW FIGHT FOR
THIS FIRST LEG.
IT IS GOING TO BE JUSTIN
FIELDS.
THAT IS WHAT THE PEOPLE HAVE
DECIDED.
>> WELL, RYAN, DID YOU SEE ONE
COMMENT THAT SAID OTHERWISE?
>> YOU DO NOT GET TO JUST LEAVE
AND COME BACK AND ACCUSE ME OF
LYING.'S
>> I HEARD EVERYTHING.
>> MICHAEL CAME IN AND PUT IN
ALL CAPS, JUSTIN FIELDS.
>> WHAT ARE THE ODDS?
>> +125.'S EMAC I GET NO SAY
BECAUSE OF THE HIGH PERFORMANCE
SO FAR.
>> VERY NOBLE OF YOU,
INCREDIBLY NOBLE OF YOU.
GREG, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I LIKE IT.
I LIKE IT.
I LIKE IT I JUST DON'T KNOW IF
I LOVE IT.
BUT IT IS UP TO THE PEOPLE.
>> THUMBS-UP OR THUMBS DOWN?
>> WE ARE GOING TO PUT IT IN.
IF YOU GUYS LIKE JUSTIN FIELD,
GIVE US A THUMBS UP, YOU DO
NOT, GIVE US A THUMBS DOWN.
>> THAT IS RILEY, THUMBS-UP.
>> THAT IS RILEY GIVING A
THUMBS UP ALREADY?
>> THEY SAID THEY WOULD RATHER
TAKE JAELYN HURTS OVER JUSTIN
FIELD FOR A SHOT.
I ANSWERED, NOW.
I DO NOT LIKE IT.
-130, I DO NOT LIKE IT.
I THINK BOTH SCORE.
I JUST THINK PETE THOMPSON SAYS
I CAN ROCK WITH FIELDS.
>> YES, THEY ARE PILING IN.
THEY ARE PILING IN BUT AS THEY
ARE PILING IN THERE IS OTHER
LOTS RIGHT HERE IN FRONT OF US.
I'M JUST SAYING.
>> I KNOW, JC IS LIKE 50-50.
>> YEAH.
IT DOES SEEM MORE POSITIVE THAN
NOT KNOW.
>> RYAN, WHAT ABOUT THIS.
IT DOES LOOK MORE POSITIVE.
IT IS A LITTLE BIT OF A
MIXTURE.
YOU SEE MOSTLY THUMBS DOWN BUT
SOME THUMBS-UP.
I CANNOT MAKE THE CALL HERE.
I DID SEE THIS.
I SEEN THIS MULTIPLE TIMES, A
LOT OF PEOPLE WERE SAYING DO
AMONTE ADAM.
>> YEAH, I CAN GET BEHIND TO DO
AMONTE ADAMS AS A SECOND LIKE.
THIS IS AS A SECOND LIKE.
>> YES.
>> CAN WE SAY YES OR NO RIGHT
NOW?
I DO NOT WANT TO START TALKING
ABOUT ANOTHER LIKE AND WE ARE
SWAPPING BACK AND WORTH.
>> THIS IS A NO-BRAINER.
>> THAT IS NOT ME, THAT IS NOT
ME.
LAUGH ♪
>> I HAVE BEEN TALKING WITH MY
HANDS FOR THE PAST 11 MINUTES
ON THE SHOW.
>> LET'S ROCK WITH IT RYAN.
LET'S ROCK WITH IT RYAN. IF
THIS DOES NOT HIT, WE ARE JUST
GOING TO BLAME YOU.
>> I WILL TAKE IT IF IT DOES
NOT HIT.
I WILL SAY, HE IS AN EAGLES
FAN.
HE IS GIVING US A FAIR SHOT.
DOES THAT HOLD NO WEIGHT?
>> I THINK THAT IS MORE OF A
REPRESENTATION OF HOW NOT
SCARED EAGLES FANS ARE OF
ANYTHING.
>> YES.
I SAW SOMEBODY DROP TRAVIS
BEFORE AS WELL.
>> WE HAVE GOT TO TALK 17.
WE HAVE GOT TO TALK ABOUT DO
AMONTE ADAMS.
I JUST LOOK AT IN THE COMMENT,
WELL I JUST TO SAY NUMBER 17, I
AGREE WITH GREG, THEY ARE IN
THE COMMENTS TALKING ABOUT
ADAMS.
WE HAVE GOT TO GIVE THE PEOPLE
WHAT THEY WANT.
DO THEY WANT ADAMS?
LET'S JUST ASK THEM.
LET'S GO SEE WHAT HE IS, LET'S
ASKED THEM IF IT IS A THUMBS UP
OR THUMBS DOWN.
THEY ARE TAKING ON THE
PATRIOTS.
>> WAIT RYAN, IS THAT YOUR DAD?
SHOUT OUT TO MR. RIVERA.
>> HE AGREES WITH ME.
HE AGREES WITH ME.
>> WELL THEN HE IS NICE.
>> ADAMS IS TAKING ON THE BILL
BELICHICK DEFENSE, I DO NOT
KNOW.
>> YES, IT IS A TOUGH ONE
CHICK.
>> IT IS A TOUGH ONE CHICK.
NOW THAT I KNOW THAT THEY ARE
PLAYING THE PATRIOTS, IT IS AN
ISSUE.
>> HOLD ON, I WANT TO WIN SAYS
TONY WITH MILES SANDERS.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO TAKE
ANOTHER ONE FROM THE EAGLES
BEARS GAME.
TRAVIS IS SAID TO BE LETTER
ETN.
THERE IS A BUNCH OF NUMBERS
THAT START WITH 773.
WHAT IS THE USERNAME?
LET'S GET IT TOGETHER GUYS.
IT IS TONY P FROM DALLAS.
RILEY SAYS HE WISH HE WAS PLUS
MONEY, ME AS WELL BROTHER.
LAUGH ♪ AND THEN, BRANDON SAYS
NO BELLA CHECK IS GOING TO
DOUBLE ADAMS ALL GAME.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S GET WITH IT.
IF WE WANT TO GO TO THE COWBOYS
JAGUARS GAME, WE HAD LOG.
I ALSO THINK THERE IS GOING TO
BE A LOT OF POINTS IN THIS
GAME.
I DO NOT THINK YOU CAN GO
WRONG.
THE COWBOYS DEFENSE IS
CERTIFIED GARBAGE.
TRAVIS AND PLUS MONEY TEAMS,
YES?
>> I AM DOWN.
>> FOR THE SAKE OF TIME, I AM
DOWN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> GO AHEAD.
>> I JUST WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS.
>> THIS DOES NOT FEEL RIGHT.
YOU GUYS ARE NOT EVEN PUTTING
UP A FIGHT.
YOU ARE LETTING ME COOK.
>> COOK RYAN, GO AHEAD.
>> THIS IS THE CHAT.
IF YOU HAVE AN OPPOSITE TAKE ON
THIS GREG, FEEL FREE.'S EMAC
CAN I THROW IN A NICE LITTLE
-200.
>> OH, HERE WE GO.
>> THE LAST TIME, THE LAST TIME
WE DID THIS -- LAUGH ♪
>> THE LAST TIME YOU DID DO
THIS, WHAT HAPPENED?
>> I DO NOT PAID THE TEAM.
>> 75, THAT IS GOOD.
>> I ACTUALLY DO NOT HATE THAT.
>> WHAT NOW?
SHOULD WE GIVE ANOTHER LIKE?
>> NO.
RYAN IS GETTING SCARED.
I THINK WE SHOULD KEEP IT TO
THREE, WE HAVE NOT HIT THIS IN
WEEKS.
>> I THOUGHT WE WERE TRYING TO
GET RICH.
>> DO NOT LET THE HATERS GET US
DOWN.
>> D ROBERTSON SAYS KELSEY TWO
TOUCHDOWNS.
HE ALSO SAID WE ARE NOT TAKING
TWO TOUCHDOWNS.
WE JUST NEED ONE.
IF WE ARE GOING TO DECIDE
BETWEEN A LIKE AND WE HAVE
DERRICK HENRY AT -215.
LET'S GO TO THE CHIEFS TEXAS
GAME.
IT IS -195.
OBVIOUSLY KELSEY HAS BETTER
ODDS THAT LET'S SEE, RELAX,
OKAY?
>> IT GET FIELDS OUT THERE,
LET'S CASH IN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> SAM, I LOVE THAT IDEA.
I ABSOLUTELY LOVE THAT IDEA.
>> LET'S SEE IF THAT PAYS OUT.
>> I THOUGHT WE AGREED YOU HAD
NO TWO SAY.
IF GREG WERE TO SAY THAT, 354.
GUYS, WHAT ARE WE DOING?
>> THAT IS JUICY.
THAT IS JUICY.
NOW, REGULAR PLATE.
LET'S PUT FIELDS IN THEIR.
>> ALL RIGHT, WHICH ONE CHICK
ARE WE TAKING OUT IS IT KELSEY?
OR IS IT DERRICK HENRY?
>> LET'S ASK THE AUDIENCE IS A
TRAVIS KELSEY OR DERRICK HENRY.
THE MORE NAMES WE SEE, THAT IS
WHAT WE ARE GOING TO TAKE OUT.
BRIAN, THE FIRST TWO LIKE OF
THE PARLAY WE HAVE JUSTIN
FIELDS.
THEN WE GOT TRAVIS TO SCORE.
AND NOW, WE ARE JUST NEEDING
YOU GUYS TO COMMENT.
TRAVIS KELSEY, IF YOU DO NOT
WANT HIM ON THE PARLAY, DERRICK
HENRY IF YOU DO NOT WANT HIM ON
THE PARLAY.
RYAN, I AM EXCITED BECAUSE IF
WE DO NOT WIN, IT IS ON ME.
>> CAN I JUST SAY THIS?
THE RISK OF GOING WITH THE
QUARTERBACK AND A TOUCHDOWN IS
SO HIGH.
IT IS SO MUCH RISK.
AND I FEEL SO MUCH SAFER IN THE
WARM ARMS OF TRAVIS ACCOUNT THE
AND DERRICK HENRY THEN TRAVIS
DTN.
>> THIS IS RATHER THAN WHO?
>> FIELDS.
THE QUARTERBACK IS THE RISK THE
MAN.
>> DO YOU GUYS UNDERSTAND?
SAM, YOU DECIDED TO TAKE A
COFFEE BREAK WHEN I WAS
EXPLAINING WHY I LIKE JUSTICE
FIELDS.
CHASE CLAYPOOL AND DEREK LINNEY
PULLED OUT TODAY.
HOW ARE THE BEARS GOING TO
SCORE POINTS?
>> AB THEY WON'T.
>> I DISAGREE WITH THAT
STRONGLY.
>> REMOVE KELSEY?
>> YES.
>> I WOULD TAKE OFF FIELD, JUST
SAYING.
>> AS RILEY SAYS FIELDS IS NOT
A REGULAR QUARTERBACK.
>> I AGREE, HE DOES NOT RUN THE
BALL A LOT.
>> WE ARE LOCKING IT IN.
LET'S GET THE PARLAY IN THE
GOOD SPOT AND LET'S TELL THE
PEOPLE WHAT WE ARE ROCKING
WITH.
>> OKAY I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
BEFORE I READ THIS OFF, THE
PERFECT BOOK FOR ME IS THAT
DERRICK HENRY DOES NOT SCORE.
IT IS NOT MY FAULT.
>> I JUST GIVING THEM WHAT THEY
WANTED.'S
>> YES, YOU DID NOT OFFER THAT.
TRAVIS KELSEY +105 AGAINST THE
DALLAS COWBOYS, DERRICK HENRY
MINUS 200 15.
>> RYAN, YOU SAID TRAVIS
KELSEY.
ARE YOU CHANGING YOUR DECISION?
>> NO I AM NOT REGRETTING MY
DECISION.
TRAVIS LETTER ETN +105 AGAINST
THE DALLAS COWBOYS.
DERRICK HENRY -215 AGAINST THE
CHARGERS.
JUSTIN FIELDS +125 AGAINST THE
PHILADELPHIA EAGLES.
THREE LIKE PARLAY THAT ADDS UP
TO +575.
THIS IS THE WEEK.
IT HAS BEEN TOO LONG.
WE ARE GOOD.
>> WE ARE GOOD.
WE ARE A BIG DEAL.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS TELL US ON
DRAFT KINKS.
IT WOULD NOT BE A SUNDAY IF I
DID NOT DO AN ANYTIME TOUCHDOWN
BOOST, MAGIC.
WE ARE GOING TO BOOST MILES
SANDERS.
HE IS -130 AND HE GOES TO +110.
DO YOU KNOW THAT YOU SHOULD NOT
GO ANYWHERE YET?
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT PARTS
OF OUR SHOW IS ABOUT TO HAPPEN.
MY MAN SAM, WINNING WRECK IT ON
THE YEAR.
WE ARE IN WEEK 15 AND MY MAN IS
WAY ABOVE 500.
HE WILL GIVE UP TO SIX BEST
BETS.
CAN WE GET 45 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK, RYAN, WE WILL SEND YOU
TO THE CHAT.
GO TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
WE WILL GET YOU BACK IN HERE
SOON.
45 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK.
PLEASE, DO THIS FOR MY MAN SAM
RICHMOND.
ARE YOU READY?
>> I AM READY.
>> 45 SECONDS IS UP THERE,
LET'S GET TO IT.
>> FIRST PICK WE ARE GOING
JETS, MONEY LINE.
LOOK, I GET IT.
THIS JUST DEFENSES ONE OF THE
BEST IN THE LEAGUE.
I KNOW EVERYBODY IS REALLY HIGH
ON THE LINE RIGHT NOW.
THEY ARE A DIFFERENT TEAM
OFFENSIVELY ON THE ROAD.
JARED GOFF HAS HAD 22
TOUCHDOWNS.
ONLY TWO OF THOSE HAVE COME ON
THE ROAD.
22 TOUCHDOWNS, HE HAS ONLY TWO
ON THE ROAD.
THERE OFFENSE AVERAGES TWO
TOUCHDOWNS LESS ON THE ROAD.
NOT ONLY ARE THEY AWAY FROM THE
DOME, THEY ARE PLAYING THIS
AMAZING JETS DEFENSE.
I REALLY LIKE YOUR OFFICE
DEFENSE TO SHUT DOWN JARED.
>> THERE IT IS, MY MAN IS
ROCKING WITH ZACH.
MONEY LINE, THAT IS ONE.
YOU HAVE FIVE MORE TO GO.
YOU HAVE 45 OR SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK, PLEASE.
THERE IT IS.
>> THE NEXT PICK WE ARE TAKING
STEELERS +3.
TO ME THIS IS JUST A REALLY BIG
LINE OVERREACTION.
I THINK THE LINE WAS DEALERS
-3.
IT HAS FLIPPED SIX POINT
BECAUSE THE PANTHERS BEAT THE
POVERTY SEAHAWKS.
TO ME THAT IS JUST AN
OVERREACTION.
I AM SURE SOME OF THE LINE
MOVEMENT HAS TO DO WITH THE
QUARTERBACK CHANGE.
TO ME, THAT IS REALLY NOT THAT
CRAZY OF A DOWNGRADE.
IT HAS BEEN THREE YEARS AND
AGAIN THEY ARE GOING TO BE VERY
GOOD AND BETTER THAN MITCHELL
EVER WAS.
AS OF NOW I DO NOT THINK IT IS
THAT BIG A DIFFERENCE.
THE STEELERS ARE GOOD AT
STOPPING THE RUN.
THIS REALLY MATTERS AGAINST THE
NEW PACKERS.
THEY ARE ALL BASED ON THE RUN.
GIVE ME A FIELD GOAL, GIVE ME
THE OVERREACH ON THE PANTHERS.
I LIKE PITTSBURGH TODAY.
>> THERE IT IS, SAM IS ROCKING
WITH THE STEELERS TODAY.
THAT IS TWO SAM.
THAT IS TWO.
WE HAVE FOUR MORE TO GO.
45 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK, THERE
IT IS.
TAKE IT AWAY SAM.'S
>> ALL RIGHT, THE NEXT PICK
WILL PROBABLY BE CONTROVERSIAL
WITH PRODUCER RYAN.
I AM GLAD HE IS AWAY IN THE
CHAT.
I WILL TAKE THE JAGS PLUS FOR.
I LIKE THE COWBOYS TEAM A LOT
THAT I WAS PRETTY CONCERNED
WATCHING IT LAST WEEK.
THEY ALMOST LOST TO THE TEXANS
AT HOME IN WHAT WAS NOT EVEN
THAT FLUKY OF THE GAME.
THEY AVERAGED FIVE YARDS OF
PLAY.
THEY WERE OUR YARD AWAY FROM
WINNING THE GAME.
THAT WAS A BRUTAL PERFORMANCE.
I GLADLY TAKE JACKSONVILLE.
TREVOR LAWRENCE IS TAKING THE
NEXT TAP IN HIS CAREER.
HE HAS BEEN ON FIRE FOR THE
LAST FIVE WEEKS.
THEY HAVE BEEN HUMMING.
I WILL TAKE THE JAGUARS WITH
THE POINTS.
THEY ARE STILL CONTINUING WITH
THE DIVISION.
THEY CAN STILL MAKE THE RUN AND
I THINK THERE IS A LOT OF
MOTIVATION TO BE COVERED.
>> SAM, THERE IS A
CONTROVERSIAL PICK RIGHT HERE
WITH PRODUCER RYAN.
LET'S BRING PRODUCER RYAN IN
HERE TO TALK ABOUT THIS AND
ALSO TALK ABOUT WHAT CHAD IS
TALKING ABOUT.
THERE HE IS, PRODUCER RYAN, HOW
DO WE FEEL ABOUT SAM'S LAST
PLAY?
>> IT HIS BEEN A WHILE SINCE I
CALLED YOU SAM.
I THINK WE HAVE GOT TO BRING
THAT BACK.
IT IS TOUGH BECAUSE I'M ON THE
LION TODAY.
THAT IS REAL TOUGH.
AS JAMES PERKINS HAD A TAKE ON
THAT, THE LIONS PUNISHED THE
GIANTS ON THE ROAD IN METLIFE
WHERE THEY PLAYED TODAY.
I TOLD PERKINS WHAT YOU WERE
GOING TO SAY AND WAS WANTS TO
THAT.
LET'S SEE IF I WRITE.'S
>> THE GIANTS ARE STICKING TO
IT.
>> IN ALL SERIOUSNESS THOUGH,
THE DIFFERENCES THE JETS
DEFENSE AGAINST GIANTS DEFENSE.
THEY HAD A GOOD GAME BUT THEY
HAVE NOT NOT GREAT.
>> WE HAD A TAKE ABOUT DETROIT
COVERING.
THAT IS INTERESTING BECAUSE I
THINK THEY ARE PLUS ONE.
IT IS A TOUGH GAME.
REYNOLDS SAYS THAT THE COWBOYS
ARE ABOUT TO THRASH THE
JAGUARS.
I WILL READ COWBOYS PROPAGANDA
ALL DAY LONG SO IF YOU GUYS
WANT TO DROP THAT, GO AHEAD.
LET ME SEE.
PERKINS AGAIN IS SAYING I AM
WRONG WITH THE LION.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE READY.
>> ALL RIGHT, HOW ABOUT CUP OF
JOE ASKING IF MIKE IS PLAYING.
THE ANSWER IS NO.
>> ZACH WILSON IS PLAYING
TODAY, TONIGHT, I DO NOT KNOW
WHAT TIME THE GAME STARTS.
YOU GUYS GET IT.
>> LET'S SEND RYAN BACK TO THE
CHAT.
YOU HAVE THREE PICS.
YOU HAVE 45 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK.
SAM, TAKE IT AWAY.
>> THE NEXT PICK WE ARE TAKING
TITANS PLUS THREE.
WE ARE ALWAYS WORRIED ABOUT
GETTING ON A GAME INVOLVING THE
TITANS.
TO ME, THIS IS A REALLY GOOD
SPOT TO BUY LOW ON THEM.
THIS IS THE CLASSIC.
THIS ALWAYS HAPPENS WITH THE
TITANS.
WE ALWAYS VERY THIS TEAM AND
THEY ALWAYS COME BACK AND RAY
DOES A GOOD JOB OF GETTING THEM
BACK ON THE RIGHT TRACK.
THERE IS A NICE MATCHUP
PERSPECTIVE.
THE CHARGERS HAVE ONE OF THE
WORST DEFENSES IN THE NFL AND
THE TITANS HAVE DERRICK HENRY.
HE IS AN ABSOLUTE BEAST.
THE TITANS WILL KEEP THIS GAME
ON THE GROUND.
THEY WILL KEEP IT OUT OF
TANNEHILL'S HANDS.
YOU GET A FIELD GOAL AGAINST A
TEAM THAT IS REALLY REALLY
DESPERATE TO RIGHT THE SHIP.
>> I LIKE THIS PICK.
WE WILL SEE OF RYAN TANNEHILL
AND THE OFFENSE WILL GET
CLICKING AGAINST THE CHARGERS.
I LIKE THIS ONE.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I HAVE NOT
HEARD YOU SAY TODAY?
HOPEFULLY IT IS COMING.
WE HAVE FOUR PICKS.
THERE IS TWO MORE TO GO.
SAM, 45 SECONDS IS ON THE
CLOCK.
THERE IT IS.
TAKE IT AWAY.
>> THIS ONE IS DEFINITELY GOING
TO BE SUPER CONTROVERSIAL, MAY
BE CONTROVERSIAL THEN MY
BRONCOS +9 LAST WEEK.
WE ARE TAKING THE BOX PLUS 3
1/2 AGAIN THE CINCINNATI
BENGALS.
TO ME, THIS IS JUST YOUR
ULTIMATE BUY LOW SELL HIGH SPOT
IN THE NFL THAT I THINK IS
GENERALLY PRETTY PROFITABLE.
THE BENGALS ARE THE DARLING OF
THE LEAGUE RIGHT NOW.
EVERYTHING LIKE THAT, THE BOX
NEVER WENT DOWN AND THEY LOOKED
AWFUL THE PAST FEW WEEKS.
YOU CANNOT GET TO LOST IN THE
OVERREACTIONS TO WHAT WE SAW
THE WEEK BEFORE.
THE BOXER NOT GREAT BUT THEY
ARE 13th OVERALL.
THEY HAVE BEEN AN AVERAGE TO
ABOVE AVERAGE TEAM.
IF YOU ARE GIVING ME THREE OR
FIVE POINT AT HOME WITH TOM
BRADY I AM GOING TO TAKE IT
EVERY TIME.
>> ROCKING WITH TOM BRADY AND
THE BOYS TODAY.
HE DID NOT LOOK GOOD LAST WEEK
BUT SAM IS LOOKING FOR THEM TO
BOUNCE BACK THIS WEEK.
THAT IS FIVE.
THAT IS FIVE, 45 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK PLEASE.
THERE IT IS SAM.
>> ALL RIGHT LAST PICK WE ARE
TAKING RAIDERS, MONEYLINE.
I REALLY LIKE THIS SPOT FOR
THEM AT HOME.
OBVIOUSLY THEY ARE COMING OFF A
BRUTAL LOSS IN WHICH THEY BLEW
A GAME THEY SHOULD HAVE WON
AGAINST THE RAMS.
THEY HAVE GOT SOME EXTRA TIMES
TO REST.
I WOULD REALLY LIKE THEM TO
BOUNCE BACK THERE.
I LIKE THIS PATRIOTS TEAM BUT
I'M ACTUALLY PRETTY CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT THEY DID AGAIN THE
CARDINALS.
I AM NOT EVEN SURE THEY WIN
THAT GAME IF HOPKINS DOES NOT
GET IN THE FUMBLE.
THEY REALLY HAVE A,.
THEY ARE HANGING IN THERE A LOT
LONGER THAN THEY SHOULD.
I AM NOT SURE THAT WAS A BIG
WIN THAT EVERYBODY WAS
PROJECTING IT TO BE.
I LIKE THE RAIDERS TO BOUNCE
BACK HERE.
I LIKE ADAMS TO SCORE A
TOUCHDOWN.
>> THERE IT IS, THE RAIDERS
BOUNCE BACK AND ADAMS WILL
SCORE A TOUCHDOWN.
I DO NOT KNOW IF I AM ADDING
ADAM'S.
I DO NOT KNOW IF HE ADDED THEM
IN HIS PARLAY.
>> WE GOT SCARED OF BILL
BELICHICK.
[ LAUGHTER ] YES, THAT IS
USUALLY WHAT WE SHOULD DO.
LET'S BRING PRODUCER RYAN IN
HERE, PRODUCER RYAN, TALK TO
US.
>> WAIT, CAN I CHIME IN REALLY
QUICK?
I AM LOOKING AT CHAD RIGHT NOW.
THE FIRST COMMENT I SEE IS BRO,
YOU WERE TRASH LAST WEEK.
I WENT FIVE AND ONE LAST WEEK.
ANYTHING OVER 6-0 IS TRASH?
>> I WOULD NORMALLY DEFEND YOU
BUT IF I'M GOING TO GET
DISRESPECTED WHILE I AM NOT ON-
SCREEN HERE THAN I AND IN THE
CHAT.
IT NEEDS TO BE 6-0 OR YOU ARE A
FRONT.
>> DARIEN 85 JUMP IN BEFORE
TRASHING YOU FOR TAKING BUCKS
AT 3 1/2.
HE SAYS HE LIKES YOUR JAGS
PICK.
DAC IS A HORRIBLE RECORD.
DR. 87 WHO IS NOT USUALLY
POSITIVE IN THIS CHAT, THE BOX
3 1/2 IS A LOT.
WHAT HE SAID IS THE JACK WIRES
ARE 23 CASH AND THE BUCCANEERS
WILL BOUNCE BACK.
THIS IS NOT THE LOVE I EXPECTED
FOR THE BUCCANEERS.
SOMEBODY SAID THE BENGALS HAVE
BEEN TOO HOT, THEY HAVE GOT TO
COME BACK DOWN TO EARTH.
JOE BURRELL, THE LAST 20
STARTS, HE IS THE MOST
PROFITABLE QUARTERBACK AGAINST
THE SPREAD.
HE IS LIKE 17-3.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN CASH COWS.
>> YOU KNOW J 23 SAID DUDE, BET
ON THE FIRE.
THAT MADE ME FEEL GOOD.
>> THERE IS A THROWBACK BEING
THROWN AT US.
IT SAYS ALL NEW YORK TEAMS WHEN.
>> I DO NOT KNOW.
I DO NOT REALLY WANT TO TOUCH
THAT GAME.
I COULD NOT PLAY THE COMMANDERS
BECAUSE 4 1/2 OR FIVE WAS TOO
HIGH FOR ME.
I THINK THAT IS A FIELD GOAL
GAME.
YES, RIGHT THERE, THAT IS WHEN
WE MOVE.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT WE MOVE
ON.
WE HEARD FROM SAM NOW AND I
HAVE A PIC FROM YOU GUYS.
PRODUCER RYAN HAS A PICK FROM
YOU GUYS.
RYAN, WE WERE TALKING ABOUT IT
BEFORE.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT IT BEFORE
THE SHOW.
CAN YOU SCROLL DOWN TO THE
KANSAS CITY CHIEFS TEXAS GAME?
ACTUALLY IT IS RIGHT HERE.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S LOOK AT THIS.
YOU CAN SEE PATRICK MAHOMES  TO
THROW OVER 300 PASSING YARDS
AND TRAVIS KELSEY WILL SCORE A
TOUCHDOWN SITTING UP PLUS 200.
I ABSOLUTELY LOVE IT.
WE KNOW WHAT MAHOMES  IS DOING
THERE.
HE SLINGS THE ROCK.
HE HAS BEEN SLINGING IT ALL
YEAR.
I COULD DEFINITELY SEE HIM
GOING 300 YARDS AGAINST THE
TEXANS.
WE ARE TALKING AGAINST THE
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
HOUSTON TEXANS.
AND TRAVIS TELLS THE.
HE HAS NOT SCORED IN THE LAST
TWO WEEKS.
THEY USUALLY SAY ALL GOOD THINGS
COME TO AN END BUT TODAY WE ARE
GOING TO SAY, TELL THEM WHAT WE
ARE GOING TO SAY TODAY.
>> ALL GOOD THINGS START AGAIN.
ALL GOOD THINGS START AGAIN.
MY MAN TRAVIS KELSEY IS GETTING
INTO THE END ZONE.
HIM AND MAHOMES ARE GOING TO
TRY TO GET ON THE BOARD
ESPECIALLY BEFORE THE PLAYOFFS
. THAT IS WHY I LIKE THIS ONE
SITTING UP +204 MAHOMES  TO
THROW 300. RYAN, I KNOW YOU GOT
A PICK.
TALK TO US ABOUT WHAT YOU LIKE.
>> YES.
I WOULD HAVE LOVED TO TAKE THE
COWBOYS -4 HERE.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN FUN FOR
ME.
I DO NOT HAVE THAT MUCH FAITH.
I WILL SAY THIS.
THE JAGS HAVE LOST STRAIGHT
GAMES AGAINST AND THAT THE
OPPONENT.
PRESCOTT IS 11-1 AS THE ROAD
FAVORITE WITH FOUR OR MORE
POINTS.
I AM NOT TAKING THE COWBOYS.
THERE WILL BE A LOT OF POINTS
HERE.
I WILL TAKE THE COWBOYS TEAM
TOTAL OVER 26 1/2.
THE JACK WIRES GIVE UP A LOT OF
POINTS.
I THINK THIS GAME GOES BACK AND
FORTH.
I THINK THE COWBOYS ARE TRYING
TO GET OFF TO A HOT START.
THEY HAVE BEEN A HORRENDOUS
FIRST HALF TEAM.
THE WAY THAT YOU DO THAT IS
FEED TONY, FEED C. DAC HAS BEEN
ABOVE AVERAGE I WILL SAY.
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE LOVE
PRESCOTT.
THEY SCORE POINTS.
THEY PUT POINTS ON THE BOARD.
THEY HAVE BEEN A TOP FIVE
OFFENSE.
THE JAGUARS DEFENSE DOES NOT
SCARE ME WHATSOEVER.
WHATEVER HAPPENS WITH THE
SPREAD OF THIS GAME, I WILL
LEAVE THAT TO THE POWERS THAT
BE.
I THINK THE COWBOYS SCORE MORE
THAN 26 1/2 POINTS TODAY.
>> THE COWBOYS WIN 27-24 AND WE
ALL GO HOME HAPPY.'S
>> YES.
MY GIANTS +7 1/2 LAST WEEK AS
I'M A MAN OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
I WILL OWN THIS.
YOU SAY THIS A LOT SAM, IT WAS
A RIGHT SIDE LOSER.
I WAS SEEING IT WELL I JUST DID
NOT HIT.
4-ONE ON THE SHOW.
>> WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE SAYING.
ARE THEY GIVING YOU A BREAK IN
THE COMMENTS OR WHAT?'S EMAC
DARIEN 85 IS I DO NOT KNOW
ABOUT THE CHIEFS BEING DONE
HALFWAY THROUGH THE THIRD.
I THOUGHT THAT LAST WEEK ABOUT
THE COWBOYS AND THE TEXANS.
I DO NOT KNOW ABOUT THAT ONE.'S
>> YOU ARE A YARD AWAY FROM
LOSING.
>> THEY HUNG AROUND.
J 23 CASH SAYS HE LIKES IT.
DON SAYS BACK WILSON IS UNDER
197 1/2.
THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
WHAT WE JUST SAID.
SOMEBODY SAID THE GIANTS PLAY
KILLED ME LAST WEEK BRO.
IT KILLED ME AS WELL.
JACK LIKES MY PICK.
AND TREVOR LAWRENCE SAYS THE
LAST FEW GAMES GIVES HIM A QB
RATING OF 111.
>> HE HAS AN ON FIRE.
>> HE ALSO SAID TRAN 5/300
YARDS AND THE CHIEFS TO WIN,
MAHOMES  ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN
SCORE.
HE JUST LIKES THE CHIEFS TO
GROWL THE TEXANS.
>> ARE WE SUPPOSED TO BE
GRADING THESE?
>> WE CAN.
KEEP IT ROLLING.
KEEP LISTENING TO THE
COMMENTERS.
ME AND SAM WILL EITHER SAY WE
LIKE THEM OR WE DO NOT LIKE
THEM, WHATEVER.
>> COOL.
RIO SAYS TRAVIS KELSEY AND
ISAIAH MANY TIMES TODAY.
>> WHERE DO THE CHIEFS SIT?
>> KELSEY WILL GET INTO THE END
ZONE FOR GREG'S THAT.
WE CAN ROAST YOU ABOUT NOT
PUTTING KELSEY IN.
THAT IS A LOT.
>> WE ARE ROOTING AGAINST EACH
OTHER ON THE SHOW IS WHAT YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
>> YES, OF COURSE.
WE HAVE GOT TO KEEP THINGS FUN.
>> WHAT DO YOU GOT?
>> I GIVE IT A C+.
I REALLY LIKE THE KELSEY PICK
OF COURSE BUT THE OTHER, I JUST
DON'T KNOW.
>> ALL RIGHT, A C+ IS PASSING.
>> C'S GET DEGREES.
JACKS HAVE NOT ONE IN NFC GAMES
SINCE 2018.
>> I DO NOT CARE.
THE COMMENTS ARE DOING A BUNCH
OF THAT STUFF.
YOU ARE TELLING ME THE RECORD
AGAINST AFC, WHO CARES?
NONE OF IT MATTERS.
>> YOU DID TAKE THEM AGAINST
THE GIANTS, CORRECT?
>> THAT WAS TOUGH.
BUT ANYWAY, 20 IN A ROW, THIS
IS MY AGENDA SO I WILL READ IT
ANY TIME.
IF HE DROPS THIS COMMENT THREE
MORE TIMES I WILL READ IT EVERY
SINGLE TIME.
HE SAYS THE COWBOYS ARE -205.
GIVE US YOUR TAKE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE
COWBOYS MONEY LINE?
>> I AM NOT PLAYING -200. IF IT
IS A PART OF A PARLAY OR
SOMETHING, SURE.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE COWBOYS
MONEY LINE YOU GET IN TWO 150
160.
>> IT IS A LEG GREG, WHAT DO
YOU THINK?
>> I LIKE IT AS A LEG.
I AM NOT TOUCHING IT AS A
SINGLE THAT.
AS A LEG, I LIKE IT.
IT IS A B- OR A B AS A LEG.
>> OKAY, THAT IS NOT BAD.
THAT IS A FRIEND.
>> LET'S DO TWO MORE RYAN AND
THEN WE HAVE GOT TO GO INTO THE
MONEY.
>> DIAMANTE JOHNSON, ANY TIME
TOUCHDOWN WITH MITCH AS HIS
QUARTERBACK +240?
>> I DO NOT LIKE IT.
>> THAT IS MY AGENDA.
>> ANYONE ELSE CAN SCORE OR THE
GAME CAN BE 9-3.
>> IT IT'S MY AGENDA.
I LIKE IT.
THE ONLY REASON I WOULD SAY I
DO NOT LIKE IT IS BECAUSE I
THINK I READ AN ARTICLE ABOUT
JOHNSON WANTING RUDOLPH TO BE
QUARTERBACK OVER MITCHELL.
>> SCOOP?
WE GOT A LADLE.
>> I AM DYING GRADING TO A B+
BASED ON THAT SCOOP.
>> I WILL TAKE IT.
>> WE HAD A TAKEN HERE FROM
BANDIT.
AND IT, 4200.
HE DROPPED THREE PLAYS.
TWO OF THEM WERE TITANS PLUS
THREE AND JETS MONEY LINE.
SAM, YOU ALREADY GAVE IT.
I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE HIM AN
EASY A+.
EAGLES, THERE IS OVER 48 AND A
HALF.
THAT IS WHAT HE DROPPED WITH
THIS TWO OTHER PLACE.
GREAT THAT ONE.
EAGLES, BEARS, OVER 48 AND A
HALF, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
I DO NOT HAVE A STRONG TAKE
THEIR.
I KNOW THAT IS A COPOUT AND HER.
BUT, I MEAN THEY ARE GOING TO
BLOW THEM OUT IN MY OPINION.
I DO NOT KNOW.
THAT IS MY TAKE.
>> THEY ARE GOING TO BLOW THEM
OUT BUT YOU DID NOT TAKE EAGLES
THAT -8 AND A HALF.
>> I DO NOT LIKE BETTING ON BIG
FAVORITE.
THEY SCREWED ME IN THAT SPOT
WHEN I BET AGAINST THEM PLAYING
THE COMMANDERS.
BEFORE WE GO, WHY DOESN'T
EVERYBODY GIVE THEIR WORLD CUP
FINAL ASSESSMENTS.
>> GREG, LET'S GET THROUGH THE
PICS.
>> WE HAVE THE WORLD CUP FINALS
IN 20 MINUTES.
>> BIG MONEY IS COMING IN ON
THAT PICK.
I DO NOT KNOW IF I LIKE IT.
I REALLY DO NOT KNOW.
I WILL SAY IT IS A B+.
FRANCE, FRANCE.
>> I WILL TAKE FRANCE.
I AM A WHEN ALTHOUGH GUY.
>> BRIAN, LET'S REVIEW THE PICS
ON TODAY'S SHOW BEFORE WE SAY
GOODBYE.
>> OUR ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN
PARLAY IS JUSTIN FIELDS, TRAVIS
AND DERRICK HENRY IS +575 ON
DRAFT KINGS.
THE ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN BOOST IS
MILES SANDERS BOOSTED TO +110.
THAT IS OUR ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN
SEGMENT.
SAM'S SIX BEST, THE NEW YORK
JETS, MONEY LINE.
SAY WHAT YOU WANT ABOUT IT.
PITTSBURGH IS +3, THE JAGUARS
ARE +4.
THE TITANS ARE PLUS THREE, THE
BOX ARE +3 1/2 AND THE LAS
VEGAS RAIDERS OUR MONEY LINE.
WE HAVE GREG'S PIXMA HOMES 300+
PASSING YARDS AND TRAVIS KELSEY
RECEIVING A LOT. THEN THERE IS
MY PICK.
MY DALLAS COWBOYS WILL BE OVER
26 1/2 POINT AGAINST THE
JAGUARS.
THERE IT IS.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS FOLLOW, MAKE
SURE YOU GUYS TELL US.
NEXT WEEK WE ARE ON THURSDAY
NIGHT AT 5:00 PM EASTERN.
THIS IS BEFORE THURSDAY NIGHT
FOOTBALL.
WE WILL SEE YOU GUYS THEN.
FOR GREG IVORY, SAM, THE MAN,
THE MYTH, THE LEGEND AND
PRODUCER RYAN, WE ARE OUT OF
HERE.
PIECE.
♪